what's going on there reject nation i am
back here to watch spider-man no way
home for the second time but this time
around what i wanted to do instead of
just giving my second viewing opinion
because i don't yet want to do a spoiler
talk i'm here with the people i talk
about spider-man no way home with the
most some i've only kind of talked about
spider-man no home with but i know
they're big spider-man fans and only one
of them is not a big spider-man fan you
got to have that one eyeball out here
but i wanted to get some fan reactions
from the friends that i consider real
fans of spider-man so once we're out
gonna get some fan reactions from them
we're gonna talk about it some more
because this
is the best theater going experience
i've had all year so i wanna hear what
they gotta say dude roll that intro
let's go find out
[Music]
literally it was fun i forgot anyone's a
picture normally i get people's opinions
for instance it's like real like what do
they think so we got achara kirk here or
atra kirk what was your reaction when
the movie was done give us a talk about
your emotional experience during this
film let's hear what you got to say i
had a lot of fun i thought it was really
entertaining i enjoyed spending time
with the characters there were some
really great surprises i'm not gonna say
anything else about that it was
surprisingly emotional as well so i i
liked it i mean there were some things
that i was like of course no movie's
perfect i think very few are but was
this a good spider-man film hell yeah i
think everyone's gonna really enjoy it
especially all the cheering you guys
have all bought your tickets so like you
don't need to listen to me you're gonna
go watch it go watch it all right we got
ourselves kyle eilerman from fan theory
tv channel kyle has a very up-and-down
relationship with sony spider-man but
spider-man is also like his favorite
character so i'm very curious i have no
idea what he thinks movie just ended
kyle i literally have no idea what he
thinks kyle what did you think so i went
in expecting to absolutely hate it and i
did and i also loved it so much what the
hell does that mean i don't know what
that means so there's a lot about it
that i think is just a part of it that's
very fanservice-y that i wasn't a fan of
but at the same time they couldn't have
possibly handled it better it was a
masterpiece and yet i also
i don't like it but i love it i have
never felt this way coming out of a
movie before i'm very conflicted right
now as far as a narrative goes i love
completed um
self-contained narratives and this of
course is not that i have to give marvel
and sony huge props for making me
kind of go outside of my comfort zone in
terms of what i like in terms of
storytelling this felt like a whole
different genre almost to me i just it
was like a whole new experience so
ultimately i would give it a positive
review but there's this part of me
that's also dying inside
this is the most weird i don't know what
to make of that but thank you kyle now
we got ourselves dan and alyssa but guys
who wants to go first
me i am shooketh
i've been a fan of spider-man since i
was really really young my dad actually
introduced me to toby mcguire's
spider-man and that became like my whole
family spider-man so i followed
spider-man's journey ever since and the
different iterations of and i tell you
this is my favorite spider-man to date i
have so many emotions
i've felt so many things over the past
couple of hours i'm still trying to
process it it was great
merry christmas dan bring it home with a
really cynical point of view
i hate everything
is that what you wanted
just be honest
i've always really liked tom holland's
spider-man alive as soon as he showed up
in the mcu i was like that guy
i like that guy this particular movie i
really enjoyed his emotional journey in
this one
more than the other two because this one
is a big choice with really bad
repercussions it wasn't just about
beating bad guys it was like it was more
of a battle of himself in like trying to
decide am i gonna be a spider-man that
just beats him up and doesn't care what
happens afterwards or is he gonna be
someone that takes care of everyone and
so i really enjoyed that
all right before
everyone's talking you guys did the best
that is
sincerely you guys said
that the things i finally [ __ ] wanted
to hear
don't edit that in don't don't don't
don't put that in we got ourselves a
jaby kawaii the movie literally just
ends to give your honest reaction i
really liked it a lot uh there's a lot
of fan service in there i'm trying so
hard not to give anything away from what
i just watched i am gonna go back and
watch it two more times once in regular
once in imax and i'm happy to i feel
like they could have done more i feel
like there's some clunky moments for
sure but
the story overall made me happy i think
the action is where i was like oh i wish
they went a little further did it a
little smoother but the story beats were
so strong for me i put it up there with
into the spider verse which is my
favorite spider-man movie did you cry
yes i did uh i think that uh at least
there was at least two moments for sure
where i got misty i got emotional i
wasn't like
full on end game crying but there were
two moments where i got misty for sure
it's funny like this i've seen this the
second time i'm watching this and the
first time i didn't i like got a little
misty-eyed but the second time i think
because i'm able to just sit back relax
and take it in i was like bawling
there's so much balling for a wide
variety of reasons for me so we watched
it with a smaller uh audience and so
it's a little bit different than having
a huge crowd where you're all cheering
together in spite of that i was cheering
i'm like no [ __ ] this i am cheering i'm
so happy right now with some of the
moments there was such great fan service
in the film so it made me happy yeah all
right we got ourselves a connie look i
know you're not used to being on camera
so
uncomfortable right now you as you
should be i have that effect naturally
even if the camera wasn't here we have
not talked about this movie but you were
the one sitting closest to me and i must
say
you were very audible with emotions
laughter
tears it was like a tennis game of just
that's all i heard the whole time
i just want you to tell me what your
emotional journey or like how you were
feeling throughout about this movie
what'd you overall feel towards this
film
so many emotions
there it is i mean
i'm still i'm still very emotional i'm a
rather emotionless person i would not
suspect that from what i heard next in
my right ear yeah
i had an existential crisis
in that in that theater
i really loved it it was fun i cried
so much you were probably the craziest
in the theater
yes at one point i looked at john i said
i'm a wreck
it's true you were definitely the most
emotive throughout so i was just happy
to have you right next to me you made up
for
it felt like there was a crowd with me
in this
in this uh ear canal so thank you
terrible yeah you're really obnoxious
you would shut up
the one i'm waiting to hear from both of
the spiderman no way home trailer
reactor together we have talked
extensively together about you you
introduced me to spectacular you got me
the spectacular spider-man blu-rays i
wear your shirt on camera because you
leave crap at my home so i'm assuming
that's why you're wearing a dragon ball
shirt today i have no spider-man shirts
left
i feel you and i have shared the same
criticisms towards the prior spider-man
movies obviously no spoilers aaron i
have no idea what you actually think
about this movie i'm learning this for
the first time on camera what did you
think so i rewatched all the spider-man
movies coming into this like literally
one every day and i think that was a
really good decision i feel like it
really paid off in enhancing my
experiences watching this movie i
thought this movie had heart i thought i
had soul i thought i had laughs it
really was a culmination like a
celebration of the past 20 years with
spider-man and it really made me feel
like rewarded for having had that
experience yeah this is the most peter
parker
we've seen peter parker in a spider-man
story especially on film out of all of
the films we've seen this is the one
that reminded me the most of the soul
and the heart of the character that i
love so much this character has so much
potential for a future and he has he has
so much uh gravitas and has such a good
heart and soul and
watching this movie taught me and really
kind of showed me that
tom holland has
it in him to be like the spider-man you
know he he definitely like i love andrew
garfield i loved toby guyer's
performance i was like wow okay he can
do it like i watched the other movies
prior and i was like okay he's getting
there he's getting there like oh oh oh
crap they did it they did it in this one
and it made me really excited and it's
an exciting time to be a spider-man fan
i do have some minor gripes with the
movie it's not a perfect film there are
definitely some characters that i feel
are underdeveloped it is still a very
enjoyable experience i've never
laughed damn near claimed close to tears
and cheered so hard in one movie outside
of endgame and infinity war and that's
saying a lot because i love those two
films you know what this i noticed on
the second viewing is that i thought
this would be the end game of like it is
in a lot of ways it is the the
spider-man end game by the time it was
ending i was like i cannot wait for more
sequels
yeah yeah no it does it's a great thing
of closing the homecoming trilogy while
also setting it off for exciting
possibilities to come and if you didn't
know amy pascal sony already confirmed
there'd be more sequels so we're not
spoiling craft free right
andrew gordon
one of the biggest spider-man fans how
would you describe your journey through
this movie i really really love this
movie i think this movie succeeds where
amazing spider-man 2 and spider-man 3
failed in terms of it had a multitude of
characters it just did an organically
natural job of you know not feeling like
you know there's so many too many
different things going on and not
focusing on a story at hand and i think
what i appreciated about this film the
most is it's still a peter parker story
this movie just really ingratiates to me
what it means to be peter parker and tom
holland just gives such an amazing
performance i mean it's just off the
charts how good this guy is this film
also got me very excited for fantastic
four because i thought john watts in
this film did a hell of a job directing
and just showed me that this guy's got
range because i almost thought like is
this the same guy who directed
homecoming and far from home it didn't
kind of feel like it but then again just
seeing all the multitude of characters
that we got and how he was able to
balance with a very interesting story
and just able to give all the characters
their due time just really gets me that
much more excited for fantastic force
and i think every spider-man fan uh is
going to be very happy with this one or
at least most of them are going to be we
got michael tesla tesler no it's tesla
that's how we call it today so it was
michael
my jewish friend one of the two
[ __ ] you in the head man i don't know
what you think about this movie did you
say that you re-watched all the
spider-man movies before going into this
one i sure did uh and i thought
that was the right decision uh and i
stand by that decision because this
movie was so rewarding i had so much fun
and i don't want to spoil anything at
all but it was just really neat seeing
things that like i'm watching in the
disney plush shows like just make subtle
little appearances like little tiny
things that for somebody who's been in
you know inside the mcu for a while uh
it was a lot of fun world building a
movie that i thought brought together a
lot of different generations i remember
watching the original spider-man as a
kid i remember like playing the original
playstation game and swinging around new
york city get all these things coming
together it's a weird metaphor but it's
like the same feeling that you got like
during toy story 3 where you kind of
just like felt like you like grew up
with this movie and pretty freaking
magical
it's like toy story 3. yeah that's what
that's the quote of the day i also just
need to say i've been part of the reject
nation for a long time even before i met
you i was a reject and so it's really
really amazing just to see you guys just
killing it and thriving and
anybody deserves it like for those that
don't know the real rejects in real life
uh these guys are really the best the
best and anti-semitic and well you know
uh
i hope this doesn't make the final cut
but if it does i can confirm as a matter
of fact that greg is not an anti-semite
i don't want that out there michael no
he's just an educated there's a
difference so
we're here with earl andrews dad gordon
what did you think about this movie well
usually i'm asleep by now but
you know back in the 50s by the way
because i am old that i had spiderman
comics some of the original ones by the
way they're worth a fortune i came home
from college my mom
said i said are my comic books my mom
said i needed the room so i threw them
out thanks a lot mom
that's all i can say is that it was a
simpler time because i got used to
actually seeing all the comics we were
kids that's that's what we have we
didn't have movies like this to see the
special effects in this movie they're
phenomenal it was great to see some of
the characters in there um i would have
liked to seen a little
more of the character uh basically
communicating with each other a little
more than what i saw but it was it was
it was fun to see them that was the
magical thing about actually seeing them
because everybody i could see everybody
smiling and cheering there were some
thin parts in it
that could have been a little stronger
but like i said it was fun to watch i
enjoyed it uh would i see it again
absolutely
that is that is perfect do you guys see
where andrew comes from you guys see it
now oh i didn't make him i was out of
town oh he's adopted oh it's good to
know yeah okay it's time for a
revelation
there's one more person i gotta get
before the night's over a man who's only
seen like
i think three spider-man moves how many
have you seen
no way [ __ ] you must see two get
over here
just give me all this crap keep your
identity concealed before the internet
destroys you we'll call this man mr b mr
b has only seen one spider-man movie and
it was toby mcguire it was uh bootlegged
just to uh
they're just still walking in the dvd
like getting going to the bathroom this
is an interesting experience here
because everyone here is a major
spider-man fan and really invest in this
franchise
what did you think about this movie
zendaya was amazing
you're the only one tonight to mention
zendaya and i'm so happy about that you
look beautiful
but you know what it was fun it was a
good time it was just fun seeing
everybody together and i cheered on with
everybody when they cheered on um
because it felt i should
you know for somebody that doesn't know
much about the whole world it
it was enjoyable and now i feel inspired
to catch up did you feel like left out
or lost no i mean i i got it
you know
spiderman got the kiss
fought really hard it was fun so that
was cool it was a lot of fun and i'm
glad i came i'm glad you came to you
always make it fun he also saw venom
leather recorders without seeing venom
he just likes going to the theaters with
us
oh thanks brandon i mean mr b
well there you have it folks that's
everyone the biggest
i went today with the
my friends who are the biggest
spider-man fans i could think of and
brandon
and i liked it a lot more the second
time it was a much smaller crowd
watching it here i gotta say i was like
exceptionally emotional this time around
and from being heartbroken to just being
moved from inspiration to heroic moments
it's beautiful it's a beautiful film and
definitely
it might actually be my favorite
spider-man movie i'm not gonna lie it's
like when you watch it with a crowd
that's smaller size you can just take in
the movie and definitely not be a
influence at all by like a massive crowd
freaking out you can just absorb the
film for what it is especially on a
second viewing while some flaws stand
out a little bit stronger to me than the
last time around it still might be my
favorite one we'll see let it let it sit
for a while still anyway thank you guys
so much for being here it's awesome
coming to cinemark
a go-to theater
do not wait for this to go out on
streaming or something watching the
theaters that's how it has to be
mic drop that i would do but i
i don't want to break this